they're known as the oyster men of the
fowl
using just wind and ore they've dredged
these waters
for hundreds of years nearly all their
catch
goes to the eu but on the 1st of january
their livelihood was banned we thought
he was going to carry on after brexit
the markets supposedly was sorted
and they've they've slammed the door in
my buyer's face
since brexit the eu has stopped british
fishermen from selling oysters
mussels clams and scallops to member
states
it's a devastating blow for tim who's
been doing this
for 50 years if i never had a bit of
money in the bank
and my wife wasn't working
i think we'd be out out of a notice you
know
it's that serious since brexit yeah yeah
there's people in here return time to
drink because of the strength of this
don't know where to go what to do how to
pay their bills
we sail over to jonathan on the other
side of the foul
he's been dredging oysters since 1975
and says that if the eu won't overturn
the ban a new market
must be found i've got a reservoir of
skills knowledge
boats and
given a little bit of encouragement
a fishery that would probably produce
twice as much
and everybody earning twice as much if
we had markets
and it was worked intelligently but at
the moment
there's little hope before brexit these
oysters were being exported to the eu
but the trade
stopped overnight the amount of money
might not be massive when it comes to
headline gdp
but they're real people's jobs
livelihoods mortgage payments
and it's all gone
the ban applies to shellfish caught in
so-called class
b water purifying it first would allow
exports
but the industry says that's not viable
with no
exports and no restaurants open sellers
have relied on local support
but they want the government to fight
get a move on
uh sort it out uh you know get some
stamina
get over to europe sort it out you know
we want direct uh direct answers to
direct questions
the government told us it's unacceptable
the eu has changed its position on
shellfish
with the environment secretary calling
for an urgent resolution
what's your feeling about the future
blake i retire this year
and uh that might all be finished i
don't know
dan whitehead sky news in falmouth